[Musique]
et si la révolution avaient déjà eu lieu
c'est vraiment cette question que je
suis môme que je me suis posée il ya
sept ans et pourtant il ya s'étendre
tout se passait bien pour moi j'avais
une vie qui me plaisait un métier
formidable de bons revenus des amis
fidèles un engagement au service des
humains de la nature depuis des années
et malgré tout je ressentais à
l'internement une sorte de tension
c'était comme si j'avais les deux pieds
posés sur deux rives qui en jamais un
avis sur la première sur mon premier
pied il y avait l'entreprise avec sa
logique de production de productivité de
bénéfice de dépenses de recettes
d'investissement et de l'autre côté
j'étais assis sur un deuxième pied qui
lui voulait prendre soin de la planète
vous voulez prendre soin les humains et
le contexte faisait que progressivement
ses deux passions qui animait ma vie
depuis des années et s'éloigner l'une de
l'autre
progressivement et sans que je puisse
absolument rien faire pour les réunir
jusqu'au moment où la douleur est
devenue insoutenable
il a fallu que j'ai choisi cinq ans j'ai
décidé d'aller visiter c'est ces
personnes qui avaient rompu leurs vie
pour se remettre au service des humains
de la nature vraiment je partis en vélo
à 50 ans ça faisait longtemps qu'il
n'avait pas fait du vélo et je suis allé
à la rencontre de ces de ces héros
totalement invisible qu'on ne voit
jamais et j'ai rencontré des gens
extraordinaires qui portait à bout de
bras les commun de la planète pour les
générations futures et on ne parlait
jamais de ces personnes là et j'ai
rencontré des gens extraordinaires qui
ont lancé des des activités pour
produire de l'énergie renouvelable
des activités pour potabiliser de l'eau
pour construire des maisons respectueuse
des humains de la nature pour partager
leur véhicule
j'ai rencontré des gens extraordinaires
qui lançait des monnaies si tu as un
local pour reprendre le pouvoir sur
l'argent d'autres qui lançait une idée
folle de donner des revenus à tous les
êtres humains de leur naissance à leurs
mots pour qu'aucun enfant ne puisse être
jours prisonnier de la misère par sa
propre naissance est ce que j'ai
constaté en regardant tous ces gens que
j'ai visités donc pendant ce tour de
premier tour de france à vélo
c'est que il s'appauvrit sait tous on
sait revient les communs et moi je
trouvais ça absolument débile que des
personnes puissent en servant les
convainc s'appauvrir et je me souviens
de moments vraiment incroyable où j'ai
rencontré marc et c'est là où une partie
de moi est morte marque c'était
quelqu'un qui avait décidé avec sa
famille de s'installer comme agriculteur
bio et c'est quelqu'un qui faisait des
produits merveilleux des légumes colorés
goûteux tout en aggravant les sols et en
prenant soin notre planète et cette
personne là elle bossait 70 heures par
semaine elle gagne et 470 euros par mois
et mois l'entrepreneur humaniste dans
une formation dans un coaching je
faisais 2000 euros par jour hier que lui
il avait cent cinquante fois moins de
valeur que moi et j'ai ça il ya un truc
qui a capté dans ma tête je me suis dit
ce n'est pas possible qu'on continue à
mépriser autant ces gens qui servent les
communs et donc je suis rentré parce que
j'ai pleuré plusieurs fois pendant ces
4500 kilomètres j'ai pleuré sur home sur
moi sur eux et puis sur le monde en
disant mais qu'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire et quand je suis rentré je
pouvait plus diriger une entreprise
donc j'essaie d'aider les entreprises
que je dirais que je dirige est un mets
salariés
quand j'ai tout vendu je me suis mis au
ciel de soie aux pauvreté et j'ai pris
deux sacs et je suis parti dans les
alpes dans la zone de retraite avec une
seule et unique question qui était mais
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour ces
de héros que j'ai rencontrés pour
les soutenir et les valoriser et donc je
suis resté un six mois dans ce centre
bouddhiste j'alternais méditation marche
consciente viendra yoga et puis en même
temps je me posais des questions souci
sapin magnifique et centenaire parce que
je veux on était dans les alpes donc
c'était très beau et je me suis dit mais
en fait le problème de ces super héros
c'est qu'ils sont isolés
il sent saucissonné c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent pas se rencontrer parce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez de moyens en fait pour
prendre de la hauteur sur la propre
activité se connecter et faire un
écosystème en fait c'est un problème
bête de financement en fait c'est un
problème de financement de
professionnalisation c'est un problème
de reconnais
de notre société est toujours entre
méditation
le march consciente et puis entra yoga
sous les flocons et insolente de beauté
parce que c'est vraiment très très beau
l'endroit où j'étais j'ai commencé à
mieux réfléchir je me suis dit mais ce
qu'il faudrait faire
il faudrait réunir au même endroit tous
ces héros tout ce qu'ils ont fait de
mieux dans la société civile depuis
design quinzaine d'années il faudrait
connecter sa entre connecter sa aux
acteurs d'un territoire financer sa
faire en sorte qu'ils aient les mêmes
moyens qu'une entreprise du 21ème siècle
on verrait bien si ces nouvelles formes
finalement d'entrepreneurs pourrait
vraiment être des outils de
développement territorial et
d'augmentation de la cohésion sociale de
nos territoires qui sont tous en train
de mourir
je vous rappelle que une commune sur
trois aujourd'hui est en train de mourir
en france ce qui est absolument
gigantesque alors c'est comme ça qu'est
née la terrasse et c c'est une idée dont
le but en fait est de re re localiser
85% de la production vital aux habitants
d'un territoire le faire au service des
humains de la nature et faire en sorte
que le territoire de vie dans lequel on
se trouve bénéficie en fait de ces
nouveaux de production relocaliser et
respectueuse des humains de la nature
alors j'ai envoyé un mail à la suite de
ça plein d'amis à 50 ans quand on est
très engagé on a beaucoup d'amis et j'ai
reçu un retour extraordinaire de gens
qui m'ont énormément soutenu qui m'ont
dit offrent un tissu père on va faire ça
avec toi c'est une super idée honteux
qu'on compte de suite et donc on est
parti à quelques heures de nouveau
pendant deux ans on a fait deux tours de
france en vélo pour aller cette fois ci
de façon beaucoup plus méthodique aller
à la rencontre de tous ses acteurs on a
visité on organisait des conférences
dans les communes pour demander aux gens
dans quel village ils aimeraient vivre
et dans quel village il aimerait finir
leurs jours en paix et puis on a aussi
rencontré des zones à défendre des
monastères des communes en transition
des fermes participative de l'habitat
partagé bref une floraison de créativité
de tous ses citoyens et on est revenu
avec quelques billes pour pour essayer
de voir comment on pourrait construire
un village 2.0 comment on pourrait créer
un écosystème pour le 21e siècle
alors une fois qu'on a été près qu'on a
réuni un petit peu cette matière une
faille trouver un lieu
et en fait ce qu'on a trouvé c'est une
petite ferme de 12 hectares dans une
zone rurale à revitaliser donc dans le
sud ouest de la france entre angers et
cahors et sur ceux sur cette petite
ferme de 12 hectares que de gentils
donateurs nous allons faire eh bien on a
commencé à expérimenter ce qu'on avait
rencontré mais sur un même lieu et en
fait il a fallu tout réapprendre
et je me souvienne de ceux de ce
publicitaire extraordinaire qui avait
bien un moment donné si à 50 ans on n'a
pas une rolex d'alou peytavi nous on se
disait s'il ya cinquante ans on n'est
pas capable de produire ce qu'on
consomme
si on n'est pas capable de potabiliser
l'eau que l'on consomme sinon pas
capables de la traiter de construire des
maisons passives qui respecte les
humains dont on aura peut-être loupé
notre vie et donc on s'est mis à
apprendre beaucoup apprendre
ça nous a pris pas mal de temps on a
touré a pris ou en tout cas beaucoup de
choses et à un moment donné on s'est
sentis prêts à construire ce fameux et
qu'on village pour le 21e siècle et on
s'est mis en marche pour construire les
premières maisons expérimentales sur
notre ferme hélas plutôt que de
construire assez c'est magnifique maison
et puis activité économique au service
du territoire on s'est pris de face le
mur de la réglementation alors si vous
n'avez jamais pris de face le mur de la
réglementation je vous invite à essayer
de revitaliser une zone rurale
vous allez voir c'est quand même venu
ici c'est qu'autant et donc voilà donc
tout à coup nous a dit mais non c'est
pas possible vous pouvez pas faire ça
ici mais enfin pourtant c'est une zone
c'est une zone rurale à revitaliser il
ya besoin d'activités économiques avant
de l'habitant il ya besoin de
relocaliser toutes ses productions pour
ces gens puissent trouver s'installer
sur place et y est restée verra non non
c'est pas possible si vous pouvez passer
même en fait nos maisons elles sont
elles sont elles sont elles sont
autonomes elles consomment pas de
ressources non ce n'est pas possible
bon on a été un peu surpris on a été
dépité parce qu'elle faisait quand même
trois ans qu'on travaille là-dessus donc
ça a été très dur à accepter
et puis sont venus les gendarmes les
officiers et là il a fallu se rendre
compte que si on continue c'était pas
une coopération qu'on allait mettre en
place sur cette série tant c'était une
guerre on était venu nous coopérer avec
le territoire donc la mort dans l'âme on
a démonté nos maisons et on a accepté de
lâcher prise
alors ils trouvent que heureusement d'un
potentiel visuel était coach et
formateur en gestion du stress et des
émotions ce qui fait qu'en gonflant le
ventre comme un ballon d'ailleurs ça se
voit je suis un peu habitué
ben j'arrive à avoir une sorte de
connexion avec moi même une connexion
avec le monde quelque chose de plus
grand que moi et finalement ça m'a
beaucoup aidé a lâché a lâché parce que
on est tous des citoyens d'un corps
social
et quand finalement on fait attention à
tout ça on se rend compte que il ya des
choses qui se passent malgré nous et on
a bien fait on a bien fait parce que
pendant un an on avait mis en place tout
un ensemble de d'ateliers de conférences
de débats de rencontres avec des
habitants avec des élus avec des
artisans avec des producteurs et tout ça
à l'effet qu'on commençait mieux
connaître notre projet sur ce territoire
et là un petit peu comme les arbres sont
connectés par des millions de
champignons les uns avec les autres et
communiquent leurs besoins eh bien nous
tout à coup ils s'étaient connectés avec
des tas de personnes qu'on connaissait
pas et tranquillement doucement sans
faire de bruit parce que ça fait pas de
bruit tout à coup et bien le téléphone a
sonné et c'est un maire d'une autre
commune à 20 km de là qui nous ai dit
écoutez on a un terrain de quatre
hectares au bord du lot exactement
découpé par le pen comme vous voulez si
vous voulez venez vous installer chez
nous et c'est ce qu'on a fait on est
allé s'installer à trentels à 20 km et
c'est là qu'on est con a décidé de
construire notre premier quartier rural
en transition alors ça n'a pas été
facile parce que si le maire et était
d'accord
il a fallu convaincre tout le conseil
municipal ça nous a pris quand même 15
ha oui parce que pour remettre
revitaliser nos zones rurales
il faut vraiment prendre son temps il
faut accepter l'idée que ce n'est pas en
tirant sur les feuilles qu'on fait
pousser les arbres
il faut
vraiment coopérer avec tous les acteurs
c'est extrêmement important mais on y
est arrivé et l'année dernière il ya à
peu près un an
on a signé l'acte de vente de ce terrain
et on a commencé à rentrer dans le
permis d'aménager alors le l'italie
comme il a déjà c'est pas mal non plus
mais en fait on avance quand même à
grands pas alors qu'est ce qu'on va
faire sur ce terrain on va pas
construire n'importe quoi n'importe
comment on va commencer par construire
un centre de formation à l'éco
construction
c'est à dire ce centre de formation on
va y injecter 6 millions d'euros et
grâce à ça on va lancer plein
d'activités sur le nôtre terrell d'éco
construction etc ce centre de formation
qui va construire tout le quartier
ce qui va permettre d'injecter 6
millions d'euros dans le territoire ce
qui n'est pas rien dans une zone rurale
à revitaliser le premier trail de ce
centre de formation c'est de créer des
habitats légers au bord du lot ce qu'on
voulait faire sur le terrain et qu'on
n'a pas pu pourquoi des habitats légers
parce que par ce moyen
on va pouvoir installer des primes aux
habitants qui vont avoir le temps
ensuite de construire leur maison puis
ensuite une fois qu'ils se rencontrent
sur la maison on pourra y installer des
stagiaires qui viennent dans le centre
de formation et ensuite une fois que les
stagiaires seront au centre de formation
on pourra y accueillir des citoyens qui
viendront visiter ce quartier rural et
se dire mais finalement en train de
transition s'est pas se joindre devenir
des amish
c'est bien plus que ça troisième élément
qu'on va construire c'est une zone
d'activité commerciale parce que souvent
malheureusement dans les zones rurales
on vient de construire des pavillons de
gens qui vont travailler à 25 km de là
mais ça sert pas beaucoup
l'économie locale donc nous notre idée
c'est de créer une zone d'activités
commerciales avec des producteurs locaux
on pourra venir manger on aura un nul
qui serait devenu en circuit court de
telle façon à alimenter le quartier
rural mais pas qu'eux aussi de la
commune et le territoire de vie dans
lequel on se trouve deux produits
respectueux des humains de la nature et
en même temps ramené enraciné de
l'activité économique ce petit quartier
de telle façon ce qu'ils vivent ensuite
de façon
de façon pérenne on va y construire une
maison de la transition qui permettra
d'accueillir des citoyens en quête de
sens vous savez qu'aujourd'hui une
personne sur deux en france veut quitter
les grandes villes pour aller
s'installer à la campagne
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'infrastructures qui permettent de les
recevoir
et comme personne ne veut investir dans
ces communes mais finalement on a un
marché en quelque sorte qu'ils aient
potentiel pour tout le monde puisque ces
gens veulent quitter les grandes villes
et puis les communes sont en train de
mourir et voudrait bien recevoir des
habitants mais entre les deux il ya rien
le projet qu'on est en train de faire un
mettre en place c'est justement
réconcilier ces deux mondes et faire en
sorte de d'aider ces personnes qui
rentrent en transition on va y mettre en
place une micro ferme bio pour atteindre
la souveraineté alimentaire un parking
solaire qui va nous permettre de
produire l'énergie nécessaire à faire
fonctionner tout le quartier rural et
puis sous les panneaux solaires il y
aura des véhicules électriques un par un
partage qui nous permettront de
mutualiser nos moyens de mobilité de
telle façon à ne pas avoir une voiture
une personne une voiture neuve et enfin
on va construire une quinzaine de
maisons pour une trentaine d'habitants
qui nous permettra ensuite de pouvoir
vivre sur ce quartier rural et le cdh et
j'espère un jour un aux générations
futures
alors une des caractéristiques très
importante de ce quartier rural c'est le
fait que sur ses 6 millions d'euros
qu'on va investir plus de 20 % vont être
investis en monnaies citoyenne locale
c'est à dire qu'en fait plutôt que de le
faire un euro on va générer des flux
économiques en monnaie situer locales
pour irriguer le territoire de vie de
cette force économique on va créer pour
pâques à grand monde sur les marchés
financiers un million de 5000 euros 1,2
de flux économiques en monnaie citoyenne
locale dans un territoire comme cela
s'est si c'est vraiment ça fait vraiment
beaucoup
donc du coup grâce à cette monnaie site
web local qui pourra être utilisé avec
avec de façon numérique
on va pouvoir regarder en fait l'impact
de nos activités économiques sur les dix
sept objectifs de développement durable
des nations unies et donc grâce à un
comité territorial du dialogue on va
pouvoir mettre en place un certain
nombre d'ajustements d'anticipation pour
piloter en fait le développement de cet
écosystème coopératif dans l'objectif
d'impacter positivement ces dix sept
objectifs de développement durable
si jamais l'expérience est positive
c'est à dire que si notre concept
scientifique nous dit bah oui
effectivement on a observé que depuis
votre arrivée d'une part il
au plan territorial et de l'autre parent
il ya bien eu un accroissement de la
cohésion sociale c'est à dire que les
gens là ne reste plus ici parce qu'ils
sont obligés mais parce qu'ils ont envie
d'y rester et bien dans ces cas là on
créera un parcours de formation qu'on
applique aux bâtisseurs qui va durer six
mois et qui permettra aux personnes en
transition de venir se former pendant
six mois pour acquérir des compétences
pour créer de nouveaux quartiers ruraux
dans d'autres zones rurales à
revitaliser les faire en sorte de
valoriser en monnaie tous ces gens qui
aujourd'hui en transition et créent du
commun alors que finalement au départ tu
as les apories nous notre objectif c'est
à travers ce parcours c'est vraiment
qu'il puisse être valorisés à leur juste
place
pour vous donner une idée n'emploie que
je cherche à me plaindre mais font
monter l'absurdité du truc quand je
bossais je mettais en place exactement
les mêmes compétences si je gagnais de
dix fois plus que je gagne aujourd'hui
donc ça montre bien que c'est pas la
compétence est pas le talent c'est pas
ce qu'on produit qui est important mais
la valeur du que le marché vous donne
or quand même la transition c'est pas le
plus beau des marchés aujourd'hui en
fait on travaille avec beaucoup de
partenaires la région le département
l'ademe et plusieurs fondations et on
est en train de travailler en ce moment
sur de nouveaux véhicules financiers qui
permettrait en fait à des investisseurs
de pouvoir investir dans ces quartiers
euros en transition parce que le gros
problème qu'ont tous et un nouveaux
entrepreneurs c'est qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à trouver de financement à longue
durée et v8 bien entendu puisque ce qui
met en place c'est pas seulement que des
activités marchandes
c'est aussi des activités non marchandes
c'est des services de délégation de
service public donc forcément ça va être
plus coûteux
ça va prendre plus de temps pour
atteindre le seuil de rentabilité qui
leur permettra à près de développer une
activité pérenne et de s'autofinancer
mais aujourd'hui tout notre système
financier et fait exclusivement pour
financer des entreprises qui d'ici trois
ou quatre ans vont arriver à leur seuil
de rentabilité et partir sur le marché
après se développer eh bien non ces
entreprises à but communaux on les
appelle nos entreprises à but communales
elles ont des fonctions bien plus
importante parce qu'elle fait elles vont
prendre en charge de ce qu'on appelle un
économique des externalités négatives
c'est à dire la pollution et tout ce qui
va dégénérer finalement les communs et
il faut aussi prendre en chasse des
externalités positives c'est à dire
mettre de la confiance entre les acteurs
maître de la coopération entre les
acteurs maître de la santé dans le
travail
m un certain nombre d'éléments comme par
exemple la confiance et tout ça si vous
allez voir un banquier pour vous le
faire financer vous ne vous le ferez pas
financer ça ne veut rien dire pour lui
or nous on pense qu'aujourd'hui il est
nécessaire à l'heure actuelle de créer
des entreprises à but communes 1 qui
réintègre dans les coups tout ces
externalités qu'on a mis de côté pour
aujourd'hui et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
va essayer de développer ce type de
financements nouveaux
alors j'aime bien cette métaphore
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter de penser
qu'on plante des glands il faut planter
des chênes
alors c'est la même chose mais ça change
tout dire que beaucoup trop de citoyens
aujourd'hui pense que ce qu'ils font ça
ne vaut rien parce que ces petits basso
n'est pas vrai si toutes les choses
n'avaient pas commencé par être petit n
aurait aucune de grandes
donc c'est super important de dire à ces
entrepreneurs humaniste en herbe c'est à
dire à tous et citoyennes qui veulent
entrer en transition et se dire moi je
veux absolument mais aligner mes valeurs
avec mes comportements de leur dire non
vous n'êtes pas des glands vous êtes des
chaînes et même si on vous écrase dans
la boue vous allez pousser parce que
c'est dans le boue que poussent les
chaînes et pour ça c'est hyper important
de se dire que demain sûrement les
générations futures verront des forêts
poussé verront des belle clairière
verront finalement une société
magnifique et qui aura construit cette
société magnifique
ceux qui auront changé de vie pour
changer leur vie ce qui glandent a plus
qu après gland chaîne après sean hoare
ont construit la civilisation dans
lequel il aurait aimé naître et dans
lequel peut être un jour eu finiront
leurs jours en paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à